شهدت المنطقه خلال العقود الماضيه عددا من
الزلازل التي احدثت خرابا واسعا في
المنطقه ابرزها زلزال منطقه ازميت جنوب
شرقي اسطنبول وكان في اغسطس من عام
1999 اسفر عن مقتل اكثر من 17 الف شخص
فضلا عن دمار حوالي 300 الف مسكن وفي
الثالث والعشرين من اكتوبر من عام 2011
سقط اكثر من 600 قتيل في زلزال بقوه 7.2
درجه ضرب مقاطعه بانا التركيه وعام 1990
وقع احد اعنف الزلازل في تاريخ ايران التي
تعتبر منطقه زلازل معروفه تاريخيا وادى
الى مقتل ما يقرب من اربعين الف شخص زلزال
القاهره في اكتوبر من عام
1992 والذي اعتبر احد اقوى الكوارث
الطبيعيه في تاريخ مصر الحديث بعد ان تسبب
الوفاه
545 شخصا وشرد حوالي خمسين الف شخص زلزال
بومرداس شمالي الجزائر والذي وقع في مايو
2003 بلغت قوته 7.3 درجات واصفر عن سقوط
اكثر من 2000 فضلا عن تشريد نحو 170 الف
مواطن بالاضافه الى الخسائر الماديه
الكبيره اما زلزال الحصيمه المغربيه في
فبراير من عام 2004 ادى لمقتل نحو 600 شخص
اعتبر احد اقوى الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
شهدها المغرب